nos invités louis georges tin président
d'honneur du cran le conseil
représentatif des associations noires de
france et antoine villedieu secrétaire
national du syndicat france police
policiers en colère et délégué
départemental rassemblement national en
haute saône
bonsoir messieurs mais avant de venir
vers vous ont bien de l'entendre amnesty
international réclame l'évaluation des
données relatives au contrôle d'identité
le moyen d'aboutir à des statistiques
parce que regarder les dernières dates
de 2016 elles ont été réalisées par
jacques toubon l'ancien défenseur des
droits cette fois plus de contrôles pour
les 18-25 ans cinq fois plus de
contrôles pour les sommes perçues comme
noirs ou arabes donc une probabilité 20
fois plus élevée que les autres d'être
contrôlé votre réaction louis georges
tin et bien tous les travaux
scientifiques vont dans la même
direction
qu'il s'agisse des travaux du défenseur
des droits les travaux des scientifiques
des travaux internationaux en france
c'est la même conclusion il irait sur
représentation des noirs et des arabes
les contrôles et même à l'époque
monsieur hortefeux qui n'était pas connu
pour être nancy raciste patenté avait
reconnu l'existence de ce fait il était
ministre de l'intérieur
cette class action je m'en réjouis
d'autant plus que c'est le cran qui a
brûlé la campagne pour mettre en place
ce dispositif législatif et il faut
effectivement que les associations s'en
saisisse parce qu'aujourd'hui la
difficulté le métier de policier très
dur mais il sera encore plus dur si
effectivement il y a une certaine
impunité vis-à-vis des faits de violence
et des faits de racisme qui
malheureusement sont légion on les voit
tous les jours il y a eu des milliers de
personnes dans des groupes facebook seul
été révélée par mediapart il y a eu des
violences pendant les gilets jaunes
l'onu s'est saisie de ce dossier et
jusqu'à présent c'est l'impunité totale
or l'impunité est inacceptable par
fortiori dans un métier qui te dois
d'être exemplaire
voilà iab aujourd'hui pourtant l'igpn
est quand même saisir 2
de nombreux dossiers vous antoine
villedieu comment est-ce que vous
accueillez cette mise en demeure de
l'état j'appelle bien sûr n'est pas une
instance judiciaire et et l'aise dans
une petite salle sur ces dossiers c'est
une vaste blague cette institution et
c'est pour ça que le dossier n'avance
pas et donc quand on est juge et partie
forcément ça donne ce genre de résultats
c'est à dire que vu ça nulle
voilà pourquoi les associations sont
obligés aujourd'hui de porter l affaire
devant les tribunaux en temps de
villedieu votre réaction
alors moi internationale et les cinq
autres associations mettent en demeure
le gouvernement dans les quatre coins de
modifier les règles de contrôle au
faciès
effectivement nous le comprends pas on
voit pas on voit qu'on va rester là on a
un cadre qui est très précis sur le
contrôle d'identité c'est le 78-2 du
code de procédure pénale c'est des
contrôleurs et qui sont complètement
encadrer la police ne choisit pas sa
délinquance
la police est au service de tous longs
mois la police que je connais c'est pas
la police mais monsieur teint en train
de décrire moi c'est une police issus de
la diversité
c'est une police qui ne regarde pas la
couleur de peau quand elle doit
intervenir ou protéger une population et
c'est le populo scenopolis aussi dans
les quartiers sensibles où les contrôles
au faciès sont censés être plus
important sur une commande hier
population d'origine immigrée qui en
fait pourrissent la vie au quotidien des
habitants qui eux mêmes sont d'origine
il irait donc en fait moi c'est un
discours que je comprends absolument pas
tout ce que je vois c'est que ça fait
quelques quelques mois que beaucoup
d'associations
beaucoup de responsables politiques de
racialiser que le débat public et c'est
la meilleure façon fait de créer une
fracture entre la pop et la population
et la police
pourtant antoine villa emmanuel macron
avait déjà avoué en décembre dernier la
possibilité de contrôles
discriminatoires
souvenez vous avait déjà parlé pareil
l'enquète qui a été menée par le
défenseur des droits
et excusez moi de dire ça mais pour moi
et puis légitimité puisque les
statistiques ethniques
ils sont totalement interdits en france
donc aujourd'hui on se base un petit peu
sur des spéculations sur des enquêtes de
terrain mené par des organismes qui ont
déjà un parti pris donc il faudrait la
scala autoriser les statistiques
ethniques dans leur globalité
mais dans ce cas là ce serait un autre
débat aujourd'hui on cherche pas à
diviser la population française on sait
qu'on cherche à rassembler tous deux
toujours dacia les discours c'est
toujours aussi mettre en opposition deux
parties et c'est pas c'est parce que
l'on cherche
messieurs je vous propose de voir ce
qu'avait a dit emmanuel macron la 4e
décembre dernier aujourd'hui quand on a
une couleur de peau qui n'est pas
blanche
on est beaucoup plus contrôlés on est
identifié comme un facteur de problème
et c'est insoutenable
avec cette déclaration louis georges tin
est ce qu'on peut dire que le président
se désolidarise des choix de la police
sicié je crois que le président dit la
vérité parce que tous les travaux
scientifiques le disent et de voir un
représentant d'un syndicat de police
être encore dans le déni quand tous les
travaux scientifiques français
internationaux disent la même chose je
me dis c'est ça le problème c'est le
déni et lorsqu'on refuse de voir qu'il
ya évidemment partout des gens bien et
des gens pas bien que ce soit parmi les
jeunes de quartiers ou parmi les
policiers mais de contester l'existence
du délit de faciès
quant à une sortie fut le reconnaît
qu'en l'état il reconnaît quand la cour
de cassation a déjà condamné je le dis
des policiers pour contrôles au faciès
donc la cour le dit le président le dit
le défenseur de droits de 10 les
scientifiques le disent
la seule personne qui conteste cela
aujourd'hui ce sont certains syndicats
de police eh bien le problème
il y là lorsqu'on a une position de déni
systématique
évidemment on ne peut pas avancer et
après des policiers s'étonne qu'il y ait
des jeunes qui déteste la police je ne
déteste pas la police mais jeudi qu' il
y a dix policiers qu'une position
détestable parce que ils nient
l'évidence qu'il y ait des jeunes
délinquants c'est évident il faut les
arrêter mais qu'il ya des policiers
délinquance est aussi une réalité
le racisme est un délit
il nie et se délient c'est extrêmement
fâché quand vous avez par exemple des
milliers de policiers qui sont dans des
groupes facebook qui tiennent des propos
racistes
jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas eu la
moindre exclusion il n'y a pas eu la
moindre sanction administrative
monsieur est ce que votre syndicat a
condamné les personnes qui avait tenu
ces propos à ma connaissance non donc si
vous voulez c'est quand même hallucinant
le racisme est un délit vous avez des
milliers de délinquants qui sont
policiers ou gendarmes cela il révélé
sur mediapart
et ces gens continuent le groupe existe
toujours et si l'impunité la plus totale
jeudi nous sommes dans un pays dont la
devise liberté égalité fraternité
l'égalité n'est pas respectée et donc la
police n'est pas peu respectée en fait
lorsqu'on refuse sanctionner des
policiers qui donnent une mauvaise image
de la police on entretient finalement
ces amalgames on entretient l'idée que
tous les policiers sont racistes alors
que ce n'est pas tout les policiers mais
qu'en revanche plié systémique
ce n'est pas le racisme dans la police
c'est la protection de raciste car vous
savez l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénal dit que tout fonctionnaire qui est
témoin d'un délit à l'obligation de
dénoncer donc il y à des policiers
raciste des policiers raciste mais il ya
tous les autres qui ne disent pas ce
qu'il en est qui donnait façon son
complice mois en fait je rejoins sur le
fait qu' aujourd'hui ceux qui dénoncent
le racisme dans la police principalement
son chien au fait qu'ils font pas partie
de la police puisque les syndicats et
police on défend une ligne et qui est
très claire aujourd'hui tous ceux qui
s'insultent qui s'insurge contre le
racisme dans l'institution c'est tous
des gens fait qu'ils ne la côtoient pas
qu'il n'y a que toi panis au quotidien
ni en un terrain moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que la police ait une grande
diversité
elles recrutent dans tous les domaines
dans tous les milieux sociaux quelle que
soit l'origine la commission religieuse
ou autre
aujourd'hui la police voir ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure quand on
intervient on ne regarde pas la couleur
de peau des individus
maintenant il ya un moment donné il faut
aussi et face aux réalités les réalités
c'est quoi c'est que vous avez une
concentration de délinquance à certains
endroits qui sont pour la plupart des
quartiers populaires
vous avez des points de deal qui sont
tenus par des fois par des personnes de
couleur dont une fois qu'ils sont
totalement blanc qui on veut rentrer
dans ce discours un petit peu
d'opposition ça n'empêche ça nous
empêchera pas de contrôler autant la
personne blanche que la personne de
couleur parce que il ya un lieu il ya un
passif sur l'endroit
il ya des comportements qui nous laisse
à penser qu'à un moment donné ils sont
en train de commettre une infraction
ces gens là il faut aussi comprendre
qu'ils pourrissent la vie je leur ai dit
le deuxième fois mais des habitants de
ces quartiers qui eux mêmes sont issus
de l'immigration
donc il ya un moment donné je veux bien
j'entends parler du jour du défenseur
des droits il tient sa position vous
tenez votre position à une autre
association nice tient à l'international
fait aussi son travail mais moi
aujourd'hui j'ai rien de concret entre
l'image n'est pas statistiques ethniques
pour vous dire oui la police et plus
comment dire contrôler plus au faciès
une personne d'origine immigrée qu'une
personne d'origine blanche qui jusqu'il
ya des secteurs indices qui les secteurs
à risque malheureusement aujourd'hui ce
sont des quartiers sensibles
ensuite dit mais si on espérait beaucoup
de temps j'aimerais j'aimerais vous vous
questionnez sur le bobo de la sécurité
du nom évidemment de la place ou qui
abrite le ministère de l'intérieur ce
beauvau de la sécurité et débute lundi
cécile coudriou la présidente d'amnesty
international a déclaré aujourd'hui
qu'elle regrettait que les ong n'y sois
pas invitée vous partagez cet avis louis
georges tin oui c'est évidemment qu'on
pour rien le sujet qui est évoqué le
départ s'est elle évolue en violence
policière et le racisme dans la police
or
d'abord les associations qui portent ce
combat ne sont pas invités premier
scandale
deuxièmement j'entends que le syndicat
alliance nous dit qu'un jour avant le
début du goût de tous ces revendications
ou d'accepter on est un peu surpris
donc ya pas deux il ya déjà des
conclusions avant même l'ouverture du
débat
et troisièmement me dis que les
policiers aient bien leurs frais deux
distances de transport vont être pris en
charge
bon je suis content pour moi je suis
plutôt favorable à ce genre de mesures
mais je vois pas très bien le rapport
avec la police en fait c'est une mesure
qui risque de discriminatoire par
rapport aux autres fonctionnaires
donc c'est un peu bizarre de lutter
contre les discriminations par les
discriminations par rapport par ailleurs
je rappelle à monsieur que les
statistiques ethniques ne sont pas
interdites en france contrairement à ce
qu'elle a dit deux fois ce sont les
fichiers ethniques qui sont assez
pathétique
donc ce sont des statistiques monsieur
du coup je vous demande est ce que vous
estimez aujourd'hui si je vous suis bien
que brice hortefeux
le président de la république le
défenseur des droits le cnrs la cour de
cassation qui ont maintes fois confirmé
l'existence du délit de faciès que tous
ces gens ont tort et que vous seuls avez
raison est ce que c'est ce que vous êtes
en train de dire aujourd'hui parce que
c'est ce que j'ai cru entendre oui aucun
problème je vous réponds moi je vous dis
que la police n'utilise la politique
violente je mène souvent à tort sans
fond eh bien ça au moins c'est clair
bon ça s'est passé est-ce que vous lui
faisiez vous avez déjà portée parce que
vous savez ce que c'est le mythe
pelletier est ce que vous connaissez
vous savez vous avez déjà été contrôlé
au faciès certainement pas donc moi je
vous dis je ne parle pas de mon
expérience de noir je ne parle pas de
votre expérience de policiers messieurs
on n'arrivera pas de toute façon à vous
mettre d'accord c'est la fin de ce
face-à-face merci merci beaucoup louis
georges tin d'avoir d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le président d'honneur du cran le
conseil représentatif des associations
noires de france
merci également à vous entendre
villedieu vous êtes secrétaire national
du syndicat france police policiers en
colère et délégué départemental et
rennes en haute saône